hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
this is a one plus two it is and I can't
show you guys yet because it's not out
yet but if you've been following along
with oneplus over the past couple weeks
they've been like teasing slash trolling
the release of various specs of the
oneplus 2 ahead of the official
announcement one of the things they
haven't actually talked about yet is the
information in specs about the camera so
they sent me one of the phones early and
I am tasked with testing this new camera
so I'm not going to be promoting it
anyway I'm literally just going to be
figuring out if it's any good or not I
do think later this year once we have
the new Galaxy Note and the new iPhone
and maybe the new Moto X and new Nexus
we're going to have to do a sort of a
full giant comparison between all the
smart phone cameras but for now this is
just a video on my experience with the
one plus twos camera and I'm not going
to be revealing anything else about it
even if I have it so don't ask so first
of all just get the numbers out of the
way I have a photo album with all the
images that I'm about to show you guys
linked right below this like button they
are 13 megapixel photos officially and
the camera app that was telling me they
are four by three photos at 12 and a
half megapixels so 13 megapixel sensor
and also pretty much every single photo
that I took no matter bright or dim
conditions was pretty much always at f/2
so F 2.0 appears to be the maximum
aperture so pretty much all the photos
here were taken in like one shot in auto
mode so just walk up focus snap the
photo and then shove it back in my
pocket and my impressions of the images
are pretty solid so far there's nothing
too insane or out of the ordinary here
but sharpness is pretty good as it
should be with plenty of light like this
contrast is on point and colors look
pretty accurate as well and dynamic
range is actually pretty healthy too
without using HDR it held most of the
tonal range obviously there's still
extreme areas of contrast where there's
still areas of total white and still
areas of total black but unlike some
phones like the one m9 for example this
one +2 usually picks a nice balanced
exposure between the highlights and the
shadows so nothing too crazy here you
can see everything nothing really gets
blown out now there are a couple of
different shooting modes in the oneplus
camera software like I said I shot in
automatic mode most of the time but
there was also something called clear
shot and then there's also HDR mode and
then a beauty mode which is just
to skin softening for portraits so clear
shot I couldn't really pinpoint exactly
what it's doing it could be better in
low light but I'm not really sure yet
because in most of my shots it was
identical to auto mode just a lot
sharper so you'll really only notice
that sharpness when you zoom in could be
trying to fake those like 50 megapixel
shops like Oppo use to and then HDR mode
which does a pretty aggressive job at
bringing up the shadows in the darker
areas and it also adds a lot of
saturation so here again is auto clear
shot and then HDR so auto HDR auto and
then HDR with the moving Auto pretty
impressive so there is also the panorama
mode which was pretty standard now the
interface guides you exactly like taking
a panorama on an iPhone and it's just
together pretty nicely so yeah overall I
found the photos had a nice sort of
balance to them and usually air it on
the side of a little bit underexposed
where some others actually tend to
overexpose and like I said at the
beginning almost every photo was at F
2.0 so not as fast as the f 1.9 or F 1.8
on the galaxy s6 and LG g4 but shooting
at f/2 out all the time means the
shutter speed was pretty fast and you
can freeze action to get it nice and
crispy and you can also get a pretty
shallow depth of field going on at f/2
if your background is further away I
also tried some lower light shooting as
well since this is where a fast aperture
should shine and it did okay
I'm not really sure if it has optical
image stabilization or not my guess
would be no based on actually the videos
that I shot so speaking of video yes the
oneplus 2 shoots 4k video which is nice
and crispy as you can see here when I
tried moving around a bit all this stuff
is handheld and even in video mode you
can get some nice depth of field which I
guess is still shooting at f/2 and it
also is particularly good that's like
really good at focusing so adjusting
focus and getting it nice and sharp to
start the video and then focus wall
shooting was pretty good too a lot of
times we see this smartphones tout 4k
video but then when you go in and
actually look at the video it takes it
just looks like muddy like up scaled
1080p or even worse so I'm glad this
isn't the case here before
okay looks good it gets a pass also you
can record 720p video in slow motion
alright so here's one final test
I brought together a couple of the top
dogs in smartphone quality right now LG
g4 galaxy s6 iPhone six-plus and I threw
in the oneplus one from last year all to
compare with the oneplus 2 camera and
here's what I got if you're watching in
4k or the highest resolution you can
that will help you see the differences
also I'll have some full size links
again to look at below here's the
oneplus one from last year and then
here's the same photo on the iPhone 6
plus the LG g4 the galaxy s6 and then
the oneplus 2 and you can see side by
side just in terms of exposure and
detail and color what it tends to favor
you getting sort of a good portrait a
characteristic of what a photo from the
oneplus 2 looks like not the sharpest
thing in the world but pretty good
exposure and Colour and again here's
another one I took of a tree trunk like
just for the sharpness and detail test
so here's a oneplus one then the iPhone
6 + LG g4 galaxy s6 and then one plus
two so again on the side-by-side it
holds its own an image processing is at
least definitely a step up from last
year's model so there you go guys that's
the camera on the oneplus 2 a lot of the
stuff you talk about when you consider
taking pictures on a smartphone is just
the shooting experience when you're
taking photos and videos with it and the
oneplus was pretty quick to take photos
I wouldn't say it's the fastest but it's
pretty quick once you tap the shutter to
actually focus and take the picture and
the focusing itself was actually very
quick thanks to what appears to be laser
autofocus at work in the hardware there
you go that's another spec laser
autofocus made the photos and videos
focused very quickly it's definitely not
the best camera on any smartphone I've
used I would I would give that still
hands down right now to the galaxy s6
followed closely by the LG g4 and then a
couple others right there but at least
if you're checking down the boxes and
seeing if this is an exponent want to
buy you know that the camera doesn't
suck it's pretty decent I would give it
like a B+ - a - given the numbers I
don't know anything about the price of
this phone but given the hardware it
seems pretty good it's also not even
finalized software it's the version 1.0
of their camera apps so assuming that
stuff can also be improved in processing
can be tweaked before the final version
I feel like
is a pretty good thing to see so thanks
for watching guys feel free to share
this video if you think others will be
interested in the camera quality of the
oneplus 2 and I'll talk to you guys in
the very next video peace